Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man venom 2
video a lot of you were messaging me the
last couple of days with these casting
sheet showing Tom Holland being part of
the cast of venom to the official cast
not just fan theories so I'll break
everything down and explain what's going
on with this it's not quite what people
think we also have some other venom
maximum carnage Easter eggs and some
venom Morbius crossover Easter eggs to
break down to if you're new to the
channel I do Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing an Amazon giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know how you want them to
cross spider-man over with venom
so we'll just go down the list here if
you didn't see the news venom 2 still in
post-production right now despite the
virus delays the movie is one of the few
Marvel related movies or any kind of
movie that has not been delayed yet this
year mostly because it wasn't originally
going to come out till the end of the year
anyway it's still supposed to come out
the first week in October so at least
there's that to look forward to even
though Marvel just completely shifted
all of their Marvel phase 4 movies of
course everyone's going crazy waiting
for that next venom 2 trailer to see
what the carnage symbiote actually looks
like and what kind of spider-man Easter
eggs or spider-man related scenes they
added after they stuck so many
spider-man moments in that Morbius
trailer and when Marvel and Sony's
signed the newest sharing deal for the
spider-man character last year they did
clarify the Tom Hollands spider-man
would cross over with the Sony venom
movies but they didn't say when they
just said that there would be crossover
and how that crossover would work
between the MCU movies in the Sony
spider-verse venom burst movies very
simple is not going to be some big
multiverse explainer the Sony movies are
just only going to reference very
specific spider-man MCU movie moments
you're not going to suddenly see half the
Avengers just walking through venom two
it's just going to be some specific
spider-man stuff before what changed
this past week is a bunch of you started
seeing Tom Holland appearing in the
official cast list for venom two making
it seem like he really was going to appear
on screen in the movie in some kind of
way as opposed to the Morbius trailer
where there's just a lot of spider-man
Easter eggs and
as opposed to spider-man walking cross
frame with the vulture more like a
Spider Man related cameo not full-blown
Spider Man cameo I literally double
checked the venom 2 results on my phone
again while I was making this video and
yes Tom Hollands still appears here in
the official cast lineup next to Naomi
Harris if you're not familiar with her
she's playing shriek from the maximum
carnage spider-man comic book storyline
just confirming that venom 2 will be a
maximum carnage storyline I don't know
how much maximum carnage but that's
where they're going with it she appeared
in spider-man unlimited number one in
1993 that was the original kickoff for
the maximum carnage storyline the way
they described her in the movie is that
she's going to be Carnage's girlfriend
but in the maximum carnage storyline
carnage just teams up with her and they
go on a tear at the beginning of maximum
carnage she is a mutant and Marvel does
have control of the Fox x-men characters
but I don't know if they're going to let
Sony use mutants or if she's just going to
be a tech based villain the reason why
they're including her in the movie is
because it's going to be venom versus a
team-up it's going to be venom going up
against both of them carnage and shriek
at the same time this other guy next to
Tom Holland and the official cast list
was Anne weighings new boyfriend in that
first venom movie he was the doctor that
tried to help Eddie Brock when he first
gets the symbiote but 3 so here's the
thing about this Tom Holland casting
announcement if you go to the IMDB page
for venom 2 Tom Holland doesn't appear
anywhere on this cast list so why would
he appear in the cast list in Google
search but not on IMDB the thing about
IMDB is that it's kind of like Wikipedia
and that anyone can edit IMDB pages for
movies you could go to the venom 2 movie
page and add Iron Man in the Avengers 2
the cast list and it would take a couple
days for someone official or someone
from Sony to go in and remove them
that's why a lot of times you won't see
the cameo scene actors on IMDB pages for
movies if they have a big cameo seen the
movie studios usually try to remove
those names just to keep the cameos
secret however some of you will remember
we went through something like this
exactly two years ago after Avengers
infinity war came out everyone was
wondering what kind of crazy cameo
scenes they do in Avengers end game then
out of nowhere Hugh Jackman started
showing up in the official cast list for
Avengers end game on Google but not on
the IMDB page for Avengers end game
so naturally everyone assumed that it
was either just an error or it was a
huge conspiracy to get Wolverine in the
MCU before Marvel phase four and then we
all went to see the movie in the theater
Hugh Jackman nowhere to be found no
deleted scenes no concept art nothing so
it seems like in the case of Hugh
Jackman Wolverine Avengers endgame that
was just an error on Google's part but -
I think that Sony really is trying to
get Tom Holland to do a spider-man cameo
scene in venom 2 like a venom 2
post-credits scene where he shows up
briefly but they'd have to film that
sometime after the virus isn't so bad
and before October because that's when
the movie is coming out and that's a
really small window of time to do a
cameo scene so I think part of the
reason why he's showing up in the venom
to cast list on Google search right now
is because it's a logical error on
Google's part these search results that
are generated for the cast list isn't
something that you can fake Google
generates this automatically so somebody
couldn't go in and edit this what's
probably happening here is the Google
algorithm is probably just automatically
generating the list based on the
association between people searching for
venom 2 in spider-man Tom Holland all in
the same moment like every time someone
searches for venom 2 News they're also
searching for spider-man news related to
venom 2 and Google's algorithm is making
the false assumption that those two
things are related and Tom Horne must be
part of the movie so it's more of Google
search just making assumptions jumping
the gun you know it turns out Google is
just as big of a spider-man venom stand
as anyone but just to clarify I do think
there will be some sort of Tom Holland
cameo scene or a much bigger version of
a Spider Man seen during venom tooth and
there is during the Morbius movie one of
the funniest things has been watching
Tom Holland try to talk about crossing
over into the venom movies without
giving any big secrets away because of
course Sony probably told him what their
big plan is remember when spider-man was
briefly out of the MCU and he said that
Amy Pascal all the Sony people and he
had come up with an idea for how to do
spider-man in a universe where he was
not part of the MCU.
The future of Spider-Man was still very bright
with Sony and we had a really really
wonderful idea of how we could sort of
transition into a spider-man without the
MCU and Tom Rothman and Pascal were really
confident they were going to do justice and
make a film of the caliber that
Spiderman requires.
obviously that meant
transitioning him into the venom movie
so they could still have this larger
connected universe of characters so
clearly they've had a long term plan for
crossing spider-man over with the venom
movies and Tom Holland knows what that
is
but obviously because he's so bad at not
giving away spoilers he just has to try
to talk around things and it gets really
funny watching him try to not talk about
it is hilarious/
Favorite spider-man
villain that you would love to fight in
the MCU oh goodness
my favorite one probably carnage one day
carnage he's so cool
and what about venom. Like a transition into
are you trying to get a scoop outta me
maybe
But no I is a very exciting time
it could be a really cool movie I think
tom is a fantastic actor and I really
think he could play that character with
a lot of energy and fear you
know do you know anything about what's
going on with that or are you completely
out yeah I'm not involved in that at all
actually oh no I can't say that. Whoops!
Nowadays, it's almost just as fun to watch Tom
Holland try to do those interviews not
giving away spoilers talking about his
spider-man movies than it is to actually
watch the spider-man trailers in number
one really cool new venom Easter egg
that we just found inside the Morbius
movie so someone was walking around the
sets of the Morbius movie in the UK
they've been filming parts of Morbius in
Manchester but making the set look like
New York City because the Morbius movie
mostly takes place in New York City
familiar spider-man home turf but they
spotted this venom graffiti on one of
the sets confirm me that the present day
of the Morbius movie takes place after
the events of the first venom movie and
at some point in that gap people have
just started calling him venom in the
press I don't know if Tom Hardy has any
cameo scenes during the Morbius movie
but there will be a connection between
those two films setting up the big
carnage twist but because Sony delayed
the Morbius movie they might also go
back in and change those parts of the
movie as well Sony's kind of doing the
same thing that Marvel did during phase
1 phase 2 phase 3 setting up fan OHS and
the Infinity Gauntlet with all these
Easter eggs through the film's
connecting
everything they want to have their
spider-verse venom verse the same way
that the MCU exists the biggest surprise
to me though is actually that they're
going so hard on maximum carnage during
venom two instead of saving that for an
official full-blown Spider Man crossover
like one that they would announce ahead
of time our next big film venom three
will be spider-man vs. venom so they
really do wind up calling venom two
venom maximum carnage they'll have to
come up with some other clever title for
spider-man vs. venom because titling its
spider-man vs. venom feels kind of
derivative so everyone let me know in
the comments what do you think the
official title for venom two is going to
be do you think it's going to be venom
maximum carnage or do you think it's
going to be venom versus carnage or
something else congratulations Ozzy man
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for
that really big video about the New
Avengers team in 2022 and click here for
my video about that venom 2 viral teaser
that the venom people were posting last
weekend thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!